here's the part that i think people
don't get yet
why is the democratic party playing ball
all right it would seem that the
democratic party ought to be
attempting to establish some sort of
reason
and to calm the situation when in fact
what it's doing is signing on to this
very dangerous set of beliefs so before
you go on why
does it seem that the democratic party
should be trying to calm
the situation why would you well if you
thought the democracy you just asserted
that yeah
and uh some you know some people in our
audience will say yeah like they should
be obviously and some people
uh will say well of course they've never
done it why would they so why
why does it seem that they should be
doing something that they're not before
we get on to why they're doing the thing
that they are
well it seems that they should be
because a large part of their natural
constituency
are white people who aren't actually
guilty of
racism and therefore need a defense and
even if the democratic party was being
cynical you would think they would
defend
a large number of people in need of a
defense and you know be trying to hold
their coalition together which involves
lots of people of color and lots of
white people and just trying not to let
that thing fray
but here's what people don't get first
of all
as i've said elsewhere these two parties
are
deeply corrupt they are both involved in
intense influence peddling so policy
does not mirror the needs of the
population almost ever anymore
in general it is serving some other
interest and it is dressed up to look
like it is
for the people and therefore the people
begin to detect that they are frozen out
of well-being they get angry they spill
into the streets
now here's the problem the elites the
economic elites who are represented by
these two parties
do not wish to share the well-being
and opportunity that they are hoarding
right they have hoarded these things
that was the purpose
of their uh investing in these corrupt
entities
and they don't want to share so what can
they do well
wait the corrupt entities that you're
referring to that the two parties have
been invested
well no the parties have invested in the
corrupt entities i thought you said
nope who's been the party the parties
have a racket
the racket is to gain power by appealing
to voters enough to get elected
and then to peddle the influence that
they win at the ballot box to their
actual constituents which are
powerful elites that keep the
entities afloat so they don't want to
share power
they now have something that looks a lot
like the french revolution
in the streets and although various
people at the new york times may think
that's cool
those of us who know anything about the
french revolution know how dangerous
this is
um so what are they gonna do well
they're not gonna share what they've
hoarded
and the street isn't in a in a mindset
to
to wait any longer right it's boiled
over enough is enough
so what's happened is the blue
corrupt entity has decided
not the police the democrats yes the
democratic party sorry blue versus
red the blue corrupt entity has come up
with a plan
which is they are going to divert the
resent the resentment that naturally
should go to them
for hoarding the opportunity in the
first place they are going to redirect
that
resentment at people who superficially
can be demonized if you imagine that
racism is in
every white head and there's nothing
that can be done about it and it
pervades the
thoughts of white people and is
therefore in every interaction and every
decision and all of those things
then you might say yeah it is that's the
reason that we're
we're not succeeding is that those
people
are always having racist thoughts that
they never voice but nonetheless
it's the reason that we can't get
anywhere rather than somebody took all
of the opportunity and frankly
the whole population of normal people is
suffering from
the uh reduction in available
opportunity
but by redirecting the anger of people
who can identify
that they're actually on the list of
people who's going to get something
right they can the elites can stave off
the french revolution coming for them
in other words they're going to redirect
the french revolution at somebody else
somebody who can't defend themselves and
that's
white people of regular means so that
thing
is yet one more ploy to
um to prevent the actual reckoning that
comes from hoarding all of the
opportunity
but what it means in this case the
two-step uh
plan to take the white house we've got
uh
not your plan their plan their plan
their
plan in is going to involve uh this old
codger that they have uh
set up for nomination decrepit clown the
decrepit clown joe biden
is of course going to nominate kamela
harris as
vp because of course it's that moment
when certain demographic parameters have
to be met
kamala harris is like the living
breathing dnc that's what she
is and then dnc being the democratic
national democratic national committee
which is different than the party many
of us are still members of the party but
anybody with half a brain
uh has no uh tolerance for what the dnc
has done to the party
but kamala harris ends up on the ticket
maybe joe biden wins because people are
so fed up with trump which they are
and then joe biden steps down at some
point
right kamala harris then would be
president
by virtue of having been brought on the
ticket
for symbolic largely symbolic reasons
it's not like people
are wildly in favor of her and then
there it is then the intersectional
madness has made a deal with somebody
would inhabit the role of the president
now of course there is another way this
could all go down which is that
um the white folks who understand that
they have been targeted
in a way that would traditionally have
been pointed at jews maybe but in this
case it's going to be white folks
writ large they may decide not to let
this happen
and my biggest fear as i've been saying
i went back and found a video on my
channel that i'd put out
in 2019 saying look they're going to
conjure exactly the white supremacist
demon
that they claim to be fighting right now
by backing white people against the wall
and getting them to identify
uh as some sort of natural entity
at the very least it's going to push
more such people into voting for trump
in november
and those that demographic shift will be
observed
in the in the voting polls presumably
and that will be trotted out as evidence
that uh the only reason to vote for
trump in the first place was because you
were
racist all along so it is this they are
creating a self-fulfilling prophecy
uh whether and without any reference to
whether or not there was truth there to
begin with
yeah and it's uh it's clear
to me that what needs to happen is
voices of reason who get the nuance here
it's not that the
resentment isn't real and it's not that
the gripe isn't well founded
it is well founded but it is not well
articulated and the proposals that are
being
um suggested are insane i mean it's hard
to give them
more credit than that they're just
literally insane proposals that nobody
who would ever
run anything of any size could possibly
imagine we're going to make things
better right society evaporating is
going to be a disaster for all of us
so somebody needs to step in and speak
to the movement about what it is that
has them angry and what
actual remedies might look like which
does involve
taking a good look at the elites who
have hoarded the opportunity and
figuring out what to do to pry it loose
from them